if you could give everyone in the world
an experiment to do for 30 days or one
activity that they'd have to do every
day for 30 days what would it be oh i
would ask them to take out a piece of
paper and write down every thought
that they've been thinking that standing
in the way between their future and and
where they are
to write down every habit or behavior
even how they speak
that stops them from becoming the person
that is healthy wealthy or free and then
to begin to
recognize the emotions
that keep them in the same state of
being every single day and become so
conscious of those thoughts behaviors
and emotions that they wouldn't let any
of them slip by unnoticed by them then i
would have them write down the thoughts
they do on a fire and wire in their
brain i would have them write down what
the behaviors look like of a great
person that they wanted to become and i
would have them practice thinking about
it and practice rehearsing it and then i
would say to them
what emotions would you feel when your
future happened because you have to
teach your body emotionally what that
future feels like before it happens and
every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who
you do want to be
you should begin to see evidence in your
life and when it comes in a way that you
least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that it's come from a greater mind then
you'll be inspired to do it again and
now we believe we're more the creators
of our lives and less of the victims of
our lives need motivation watch our top
10 with believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best dr joe
dispenza and my take on his top 10 rules
for success enjoy
rule number two have elevated emotions
if you said well listen i'm not going to
wait for my healing
to feel gratitude i'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
i'm going to actually teach my body
emotionally
what that future feels like before it
happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer world to change our inner world
right waiting in person waiting is not
creating i mean period and when people
are they could have the greatest
intentions in the world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion
there's no signal because the elevated
emotion is the carrier it's the energy
that carries the thought
so then
when we're in separation in lack waiting
for our wealth to feel abundance we're
basically living our whole life in pain
right so then if you reason this and a
person can get up from their meditation
and they literally feel differently
and they're feeling the emotions of
their future before it happens this is
turning
the whole process around
they can't be looking for it why would
they be looking for it if they felt like
it there it already happened now there's
no separation now this is
when those serendipities and
coincidences and opportunities begin to
show up in people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they
start believing they're more of the
creator of their life yeah and less of a
victim of their life rule number three
change the pattern with a community of
like-minded like like
similar energy of people
uh everybody understands they get one
another you know you you communities
tends to be the thing now that in terms
of our
uh social media and the feedback we're
getting
everybody wants more community because
you get a you get a thousand people an
audience and their energy is
synchronized now you're looking at
something so much bigger we're just
going to measure this i just talked to a
researcher yesterday
we're going to measure
a thousand people when they reach that
synchronized moment when they're we can
we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're
producing a ambient coherent magnetic
field in your heart and
you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering and co-mingling with
the person who's next to you when that
energy starts to synchronize
it's going to produce a bigger wave the
higher the amplitude the higher the wave
the more energy there is so now you have
one mind and one heart and now when it
comes to healing others and we've done
the research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field
that's that that has to be changed so
once people start reversing this then
you start seeing the tumors disappearing
you start seeing blind people seeing
deaf people hearing you start seeing
people with parkinson's disease switch
on i mean you start seeing
stage four cancers reversing because now
they're you're you're you're swimming
upstream you're going to the headwaters
and making that change rule number four
lead with your heart it's so important
then that of the infinite places you can
put your attention
let's put it on your heart
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy why because
we want this center to bloom
fourteen hundred thirteen hundred
different chemicals that we storm
regenerate the body let's breathe let's
open this up let's practice this let's
learn how to lead with a heart a
different consciousness yeah in the
beginning
it's a little difficult but
you stay with it and you practice it
pedal by pedal by pedal placing your
attention there you're putting your own
life force back into your heart you're
turning your love inward and the body
will start responding and in a week's
time if we're doing that three times a
day or over and over again
sooner or later that thing is going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood
this center
when you start feeling love you make a
chemical called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing factor you know
what that is it causes the arteries in
your heart to literally open up so your
heart is going to be filled with blood
and oxygen and nutrients it's
physiological it's going to feel full
you're going to have a hard on in a
sense your heart is going to fill right
and when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over i mean it is
and people are in they're sobbing
because they realize that this this
center finally like a child also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five change your energy i
think we're all faced with great
opportunities brilliantly disguised as
impossible situations
and in order like for me personally and
i and after looking through your book
and reading a good portion of it i mean
for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before
so
we could we
problems or challenges in our life and
as a side note i was having breakfast
with a researcher just last week who's
studying what happens when we perceive
and condition in our environment as a
problem how it weakens the organism
they're measuring this and when a person
sees it as a challenge how they draw
energy they raise the energy of their
body back into order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what but you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate
from that experience you're involved in
it and how you think and how you feel
broadcast energy into the field so your
energy is the same every day and as long
as your energy is the same nothing's
going to change in your life either and
nobody changes until they change their
energy so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know
all right well certainly somebody in
history has faced this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times
well hell i had the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure is not a thing i got
to overcome failure well yep just
climbed a step yeah okay i'm reacting to
that circumstance with the same emotion
that emotion is firing the same thoughts
i'm broadcasting the same energy into
the field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stopped forgetting and when we
get to that point now we're conscious
now there's wisdom and wisdom is the
memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create reality when
things are good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow
your objectivity in not reacting
emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation rule number six
become conscious
consciousness is awareness awareness is
paying attention and noticing and so 95
of who we are by the time we're 35 years
old is a set of unconscious automatic
programs that we've just practiced so
many times that we're not consciously
thinking about those so in order for you
to change to answer the initial question
that you asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you got to you got to start looking
at those hardwired thoughts that that
you think every day that are just
circuits that have been fired and wired
together how do we do that should we
write a list at the end of the day or
whatever the most common thoughts we had
that day like how does someone become
aware you don't have to do that you just
have to sit down close your eyes and not
move and then you'll get you'll you'll
start seeing what am i thinking about
right now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program but thinking about the thinking
yeah who's doing the thinking of the
thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act become so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you gotta say oh my god
this feeling that i've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
i didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me
and all of a sudden as you start
becoming conscious of it you're
beginning to objectify your subjective
self you're you're pulling out of those
programs and nobody likes to do that
because it's uncomfortable they'd rather
turn on their cell phones start texting
get on the internet
you know watch tv to distract them from
that moment and that is what they have
to move through in order to get to their
to their own personal freedom so the
first step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious
of your unconscious self that you won't
go unconscious to any thought any
behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you gotta
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh i mean
how many times have i done it thousands
but i'm not going to give up because
the moments
in which i do connect or the moments
that i do have that transcendental
experience
what matters the most after it when i
have that transcendental moment i look
back
at all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you want to live further and you said
i'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further
or
you had a rough day and you just went in
and you just you at the end of the day
you surrender and you have the classic
oh my god moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
um you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me um staying
conscious and staying aware and staying
present
is an art because
you you know when someone's present with
you in your life because they're paying
attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this
this this intelligence that lives within
you and i that's governing everything
material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it
as well as you can get present with
anything else and just because you can't
see it doesn't mean it doesn't exist
that that that realm you can't
experience with your senses you can only
experience with your awareness
so then
people have to take their attention off
their bodies and go from a somebody to a
nobody take their attention off the
people in their life and go from that
they identify with and go from a someone
to a no one take their attention off the
things in their life their cell phone
their computer their car and go from
something to nothing take their
attention off where they sleep where
they work where they're sitting and go
from somewhere to nowhere take their
attention off the predictable future in
the familiar past and time and go from
some time to no time and now if you're
taking all of your attention off of
everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
consciousness and now
that is the bridge that is the door to
the quantum field and you can't enter
the quantum field as a somebody so
if someone has spent their whole life
working on having the perfect body or so
much so they have so much attention on
their pain
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy it's going to take
some work for them to take all of their
attention off their body right because
they'll go they'll do it and then
they'll go back let's see if the pain's
still there oh the pain's still there so
it's a little bit of a waltz in the
beginning but as people start applying
this
you start getting better at it rule
number seven invest in yourself let's
demystify meditation because it has so
many stigmas around it close your eyes
retreat from your life
disconnect from your body disconnect
from your environment disconnect from
your schedule and just give yourself an
hour or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because
when you invest in yourself you invest
in your future and when you believe in
yourself
you believe in possibilities and when
you believe in possibilities you believe
in yourself and if you don't believe in
possibilities then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming the new normal yes and you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make
to connect is is amazing because
that which we are seeking is seeking us
it's not like
it is it matches our efforts
and so then when when people have that
uncompromising will
the same way that they go shopping for a
dress or a pair of earrings or go to the
gym and work out with the same intensity
with the same passion
come up against themselves and just say
when the body's going given everything
it has it's when you say that's all you
got that's it that's all you're going to
put out to work i'm ready
and so then
when you start overcoming that yeah the
side effect of it is that all of a
sudden you're happy for no reason
and you're less seduced in believing
that something else you need something
outside of that outside of you to make
you feel better all of a sudden you're
feeling better every day without
anything outside of you
and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
you're saying that ed guy he's different
he's on a different medication
but in actuality you're just freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
divine in us that in essence in us the
side effect is we become more willful we
become more mindful we become more
conscious we become more loving it's
it's it's nature you know it's just it
just it comes becomes who we are rule
number eight break the chains at the end
of the day if you really wanted to be
wealthy say
how did i do today did i make the right
choices was i ethical was i purpose
driven was i was i was am i interested
in making a difference was i fair was i
tempered
did i really think before i spoke what
did i remember reading about that book
about that person that did it how'd i do
and if you said i when did i fall from
grace when did i lose it okay
i want that opportunity again i want
another shot at that and i'm going in
this way what would love do in this
situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process uh if we're if we really learn
and we really get it
but the trial and error is so
important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and in their own because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and i always say the
same thing to him
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am i not
healed
you're still the old person
you're going to become that person every
day right
turns out that when you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are
they are out of the bleachers and
they're on the playing field
and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said god i i always
thought that
this work really worked
these concepts are the truth but i never
believed it worked for me
and i was in a car accident in a
wheelchair and she made the decision
that she was going to overcome that
belief now it was no longer about her
healing it was about overcoming the
belief but she overcame the belief and
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities when you believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and that's
why people don't do the work i mean if
you you believe that your thoughts
create a reality you would show up every
day and create and so a lot of people
believe in their past more than they
believe in their future a lot of people
fall in love or more in love with their
past or romance their past instead of
romance their future or love their
future it's it's that simple so the
initiation process of life
is always going to be there you're
always going to be challenged if if you
want to be a master well then you better
learn how to heal someone else and
you're going to fail a lot of times and
if you think that you're a failure then
you'll quit but if you feel like you
just didn't quite ding it yet and you
show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can i open my heart how much more
can i surrender into this infinite field
how much more can i become can i walk is
it with my eyes open people
do meditations and they have great
meditations me included
and then you get up you open your eyes
and you're back in the program and
people want to know why they haven't
healed them we have testimonies of
people
they're speaking the truth they said my
ms
my rheumatoid and my lupus never went
away
i had great meditations i felt better
and then i realized with my eyes open i
was still that person and now
next level they're in the game catching
themselves or catching how they speak
they're watching how they think they're
not letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing it now this is the this is the
great part and when the person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
freedom that happens
they look back at their past they want
to change one thing in their past
because it brought them to that present
moment that's the path no longer
existing that's the freedom so is it
worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
rule number nine work on yourself i will
never work in a relationship i just
won't if i'm working in a relationship
something's wrong i work on me
i'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't then i'm going to step back and
see what is it about me not you what is
it about me that i need to really look
at and change now
if there's a vibrational match and it
flows and it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally mind body soul you
know that's cool i i think that's
healthy
but a mission driven person can't be in
a relationship where you have to keep
going back
and and and trying to fix something i
just i just won't do that i just think
that when it when it's right it's right
and i'll know
yeah yeah
so i think that i do think that uh
relationships uh can be easy
and i i do think i i and i think that
they should be
and i and i think that if you're
heart-centered
uh that's a different place you meet
uh than than
other emotions and and
and i and again every time i have a
mystical moment
and i feel that
transcendental love that i don't even
know the word for
uh every time i have one of those
moments i think i got this all wrong
it's just that it it's it is not
chemical it's electric and you got what
all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we i mean we don't see things how they
are we see things how we are you know
and every inner experience that's
transcendental experience enriches
circuitry in your brain experience
produces
emotion or energy in the body so you
start having transcendental moments
where you start connecting to that field
its signature is love i mean but not
love like a love for your puppy
it's this is like this is like an
arousal this is i don't know the other
word but spiritual arousal yeah and we
have the we have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
i'll say oh um watch she's gonna pop in
a few minutes what do you mean just
watch she's gonna pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
survival in the environment that
produces the arousal this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss arousal is ecstasy
the arousal is freedom
but it's it's it's not chemical it's
it's you'll feel it in every single cell
in your body now here's the outcome of
that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layers been
removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so
when you start having moments where you
hit that kind of frequency or you have
those moments of love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness
you're you're okay you can love the
person for their flaws
because you can see a part of yourself
you used to be that you no longer aren't
instead of judgment you have compassion
and you can encourage and and and
communicate from from a level of
connection instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
works and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips
is have fun what are the three things we
should say when we wake up in the
morning or think
well first i would say
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
and i would not get up until i felt like
that person
the second thing i would say is can i
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if i do it properly then i will
be open to opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing i would say is could i
sustain
brain and heart coherence to the point
where that intelligence within me that's
giving me life begins to find the door
to open out so i can begin to see
evidence in my world what would you say
every evening before you go to sleep oh
yeah how did i do this thing how did i
do how did i do how did i do today i
mean one day one lifetime yeah how did i
do today did i change or help another
human being did i really change
someone's future future timeline lastly
what is the greatest thing i learned now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
the comments below so i can celebrate
you i have three kids and i've raised my
kids with these principles and and i
think uh there are critical periods ed
where
certain information uh is more
understood
in certain periods where uh you can you
can really advance
a teaching or an understanding
but the children you know their first
six years of their life they're very
suggestible to information and their
brain waves are just in a slower pattern
so they don't have any critical
facilities or analytical facilities so
big boys don't cry little girls should
be seen and not heard money is the root
of all evil god is mad at you you're
going to go to hell so kids just take
that all in without any filter and that
becomes the foundation of their
personality and our identity
then you throw in parents
that are 95 of the time running
unconscious programs while children have
mirror neurons
and mirror neurons emulate behavior so
when you were feeding your kids when
they were young you took that spoon and
you went like this
you didn't know you were doing that but
you were doing that and they were
watching you and you were watching them
and they were they were turning on the
same circuits in their brain that you
were turning on
just so they could model the behavior so
so then you can't say the kid stop being
an emotional basket case because they're
not listening to anything you're saying
they're observing behavior so when a
lioness takes her cubs out to hunt they
sit and they watch her
and they're when they're watching her
she's priming their brain they're
actually going to emulate her behavior
so as they start observing her
they start turning on the same circuits
they will when they hunt so they start
imprinting it right
so then
with children then
i call it the fast path to enlightenment
because if you want to raise a great kid
you got to be the example
and so
um
you know there's certain principles with
children uh in certain critical periods
you don't tell your kids when they're
four years old you create your reality
fix this you know it's not they're not
ready for that but there are certain
things at certain periods of time that
are really healthy and teaching children
had a short and refractory period of
their emotional reactions is so
important and simple things like a
trampoline
is a great way when a kid is upset
just change their state let's go yeah
let's go okay and they jump and you jump
with them 10 minutes later
it's gone isn't that true and so then
you're teaching them that kind of
emotional intelligence
parents need to know
that it's so important to understand
and never
rationalize with your kid when they're
emotional
why because do you want to hear anything
when you're emotional you want to be
left alone because no new information
can enter their nervous system that is
not equal to the emotion that they're
experiencing it's not relevant
so then
getting them past their
emotional state and teaching them how to
shorten their refractory period and then
timing okay when they start getting
ready for bed and it's getting loving
and it's getting quiet and they're
settling down
you get in bed with them and you lay
there and you say
you know i had a tough day today
i've been working on my frustration you
know and i didn't do very well today i
just i got angry at a few points i got
frustrated and i stayed that way for
like three hours
and you just open the door for kids and
they'll say yeah you know i was playing
today
and they'll go automatically said and i
got so frustrated with my friend paris
you know
and i'll say well that's all right you
know that's normal we all do that but
what i care about the most
is that if you had another opportunity
tomorrow in the same situation how would
you do it better
and then they'll say well i would do
this and then say really if you do that
this is probably going to happen so
let's work on this together overcoming
the old self
allows us to become somebody else and
there is that period of transition yeah
i call it the void where there's just
not a lot happening
and you just got to be able to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop i
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone
this weekend
broke through to the other side
and now there's so much magic happening
around this person but she's worthy now
to receive it and that's that
that is the key because the universe
only gives us what we think we're worthy
of receiving so we gotta become
initiated into this and understand it
thousands of years of programming that
says that we have to change things uh
matter to matter you know in
three-dimensional reality and it will
take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on i think this is a time in history
where it's not enough to know there's a
time in history to know how
and if you rewind the tape 10 years ago
you know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in 10 years ago
when i went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because when doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself yeah you're
gonna get uncomfortable right
and um
i think we're in an age of information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of technology we
have access to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change i think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
education model journalism uh
the economy you know uh
politics it's all beginning to uh
come to the surface because something
else has to come out and and i think
that one of the things that people are
realizing is that you don't have to be a
buddhist monk to do this or a nun with
40 years of devotion you just got to
understand the formula and just like any
skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it if we teach a
person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a cannon and shoot them to the
moon now what are you gonna do sooner or
later you gotta reckon with yourself and
change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well i can't feel
gratitude and i say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny you've got to maintain
that modified state of mind and body
your entire day
independent of the conditions in your
outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready because something weird or
unusual some synchronicity some
coincidence some opportunity is going to
land in your lap and you didn't have to
go and get it yes it came to you now
you're the vortex of creation so if you
say to me well i was feeling gratitude
but then there was traffic or my
co-worker sent me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life we
define reality with our senses and i
think that is one of the biggest
delusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the event has already occurred
now the latest research in plasticity
says that's absolutely possible and can
you select a new possibility in the
quantum field and begin to emotionally
embrace that future every single day to
such a degree that your body
as the unconscious mind
the objective mind does not know the
difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to signal new genes and new ways
to change your body
to look like the experience has already
happened now yes the latest research in
epigenetics says it's absolutely
possible now think about this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future that your body begins to
change to look like it's already
happened now this is where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it
now it begins to come to you you become
the vortex or the magnet to your destiny
so then people who come out of their
meditation and they say well i just
focused on my wealth why isn't it there
well you're not that good if you're
asking why isn't it there you're back to
the old person again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then
see what kind of effects begin to take
place without moving into impatience
without moving into frustration without
starting to analyze why it hasn't
happened or when that is the trap of
defining reality with your senses so you
have the thought of your future and you
don't see it then you experience
separation
but people who are practicing this work
they have the thought of their future
and they feel the emotion of their
future they're still connected to it
right so that takes practice and it's
just learning like hitting a golf ball
hitting a tennis ball dancing with salsa
you know crocheting whatever it is you
gotta you gotta start out staying real
conscious and learning then you get good
at it and it gets to be instrumental it
gets to be fun and that's that's what i
want for everybody that the act of
creation
should be a blissful playful ecstatic
loose
free process and um
and so
i love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future
then they're not living by the memories
of the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people
the unknown is a scary place
so they don't see that future
because they're used to seeing that
future with evidence with their senses
and you have to be able to get beyond
that and stay in the unknown stay in
that discomfort and then in that moment
to be begin to self-regulate like oh i'm
starting to feel a little anxiety ooh
i'm starting to feel a little
frustration
that's the defining moment where your
body's going back to the past because
emotions are a record of the past or you
go into routine again so you catch
yourself
it's a victory
and if you keep catching yourself those
victories add up and it's not so much
about your wealth or your health or your
freedom or your new relationship
it's actually about who you become we
have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week
will lengthen your life the telomeres
the little shoestrings on the end of
your dna get longer that means your
biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's
having a transcendental moment and we
now know that we can predict it and we
now know that we can induce it i think
uh you know if we everything starts with
a thought i mean everything that you do
in your life you you have to have a
thought before you initiate an action
right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places and the
moment they start start turning on those
circuits those memories are actually
causing them to think in the past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the they recall some problem in their
life they start feeling unhappy they
start feeling discouraged they start
feeling anxious now thoughts of the
language of the brain and feelings of
the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts and you can't think
greater than how you feel or feelings
have become the means of thinking you're
thinking in the past your lens of the
future is going to be colored by the
past so you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
yes enough to see well the challenge is
is that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain the nerve cells
that fire together wire together so all
of a sudden you start getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time those
thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so some people
would rather cling to the familiar than
take a chance and possibilities so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well when
you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
re-mold the brain when you're feeling
gratitude and your heart is open you're
broadcasting energy into the field
frequency the frequency you lay the
intent of the thought of your health or
your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know
the moment you disconnect from the
energy of your future because of some
circumstance in your life and you lose
that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now that requires great awareness
and great effort but if you have a
community of people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis
and they're connected to their future
because that's where their their mind is
they begin to
want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
nitric oxide from oxytocin and then all
of a sudden your heart literally starts
to swell it literally begins to open up
and there's more energy going there and
now you're coming from a different level
of mind you have to really begin to
mentally rehearse
like so you ask yourself at the end of
your day i do this every day how'd i do
how'd i do today bro how did you do did
you do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student
of life
you'll begin to contemplate well it was
that person that said that thing then i
reacted or this i got this email or
things didn't go my way and i started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could i evolve my experience now you
may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go now the next time that
happens i think i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the future and if you keep
installing that hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently
that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time that means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so
by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute i just
need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't
fall from grace they don't allow their
energy to drop and so yeah in the
beginning
it takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness
to stay conscious and not go unconscious
but if you're persistent and you're
determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say
i am not going to give my power away to
that person or that circumstance when i
can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say i had a
hard day yesterday at a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and i don't feel
like doing the work well
that's the time to get back on the horse
yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they
we say got lit up they connected and
their brain goes into very very high
coherent states and super gamma patterns
that are way outside of normal and they
have a transcendental download or
connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past
because it got them to that moment
that's the moment the past no longer
exists now by the same means
they look back at their past
and they see all those tough moments
where they overcame themselves and they
fall in love with that person they don't
look at the good meditations or the
things that went well they look they
know that it was those moments that got
them to this moment and i i think then
that's when they begin to understand
that that all of the hard work
all the effort
in who we become makes no one can take
that away from us so then once we arrive
at that level and we experience whatever
the dream is or whatever we create the
next thing is do it until you fully
enjoy it and then when it gets boring or
predictable let's go again let's do
something else our research shows that
when you get a community of people
together
and they begin to open their hearts and
they they have the intent for the
greatest good for people that they know
or people that they could focus on
that our research shows that you can
actually affect another person's
autonomic nervous system when you move
into hard coherence in a very non-local
way well what's the significance of that
well we have an amazing community
and our community is connected by these
elevated emotions those other emotions
of survival create separation but we we
work to open our hearts and to feel
connected
we can begin to affect people in a very
non-local way
in other words everybody else's hearts
go into coherence at the exact same time
you by opening your heart
strengthen your connection to this
community you strengthen the connection
to the people that you relate with in
your life the majority of our thoughts
and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering our shame our unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival
and those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion
stress
is a lot of energy that we're drawing
from our very vital life force yes a
resource of light and information and
we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so so then living like that
for the short term is okay because the
body can move back to homeostasis and
restore itself but when we're over doing
that consistently then there's no energy
for growth and repair there's because
you're living constantly in survival so
again you can eat all the right food you
can do all the right things but if
you're living in anxiety and fear and
you're viewing your world from the worst
case scenario that could possibly happen
because that's what you do in survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so the
majority of our thoughts
are signaling certain circuits in the
brain that signal another part of the
brain limbic brain to make what's called
a neuropeptide neuropeptides are
chemical messengers that signal hormonal
centers so now you're taking thought
and you're storing it as energy in these
energy centers and and if you're living
in survival why would you open your
heart i mean it's just not a time to
open your heart i mean if you're getting
chased by t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fight or hide and so is that why
we're this way i've never asked you this
before is this some
uh i don't i don't think you believe
this but one understands is this some
sort of genetic disposition that's been
passed down to us since we've been
chased by t-rex i think so i think
survival has been very adaptive yeah
like because if you're being chased by
t-rex you don't run up to
t-rex and say oh cute little dinosaur
let me pet you that's not adaptive and
fear is adaptive you run from the
unknown you run from challenges right
yes so if you're living in survival
there's better chances of surviving
if you run from the unknown and by the
way when you're living in survival at
the infinite potentials in the quantum
field
you'll select the worst case scenario in
your mind
and you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because you have better chances of
surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought and emotion or
an image and an emotion you're branding
or conditioning your body into what
anxiety right into fear so then you keep
doing that over and over again over and
over again your the body becomes the
mind of fear and
whether you think you can control it or
not you're gonna have a panic attack and
the panic attack is the body's saying
you've conditioned me this way try as
you may with your conscious mind and
control it right you programmed it
subconsciously then you start worrying
about the next panic attack and it's
that very anticipation
keeps the person on the hamster wheel
robs them of all of this energy as well
they're absolutely so so so they don't
believe in possibility when they're
living in that state because in survival
it's not a time to create all the blood
flow is going to the hind brain and away
from the forebrain there's no there's
there's no physiology really for a
person to begin to create a new future
so then so think about it so then
70 of the time people in the world are
living anticipating the next moment
based on their past moment and so
they're laying reality down moment by
moment with the next known the next
predictable moment and so the hormones
of stress endorse the senses our senses
become heightened when we're under
stress
and we become materialists we narrow our
focus on the danger yes so then you're
focusing on matter you're focusing on
the material world and when you do that
you put all your attention the arousal
of the stress hormones puts all your
attention on your body if you're being
chased by t-rex you better be paying
attention to your body if you believe
that your thoughts have something to do
with your destiny
that your thoughts create your life
let's examine the thoughts that you
think
now you think sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts in one day
out of those sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts that you think in one day
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before
so the same thoughts will always lead to
the same choices
the same choices will always lead to the
same behaviors
the same behaviors will always create
the same experiences
and the same experiences always produce
the same emotions and those same
emotions then drive our very same
thoughts
and our biology
our neural circuitry our neurochemistry
our neurohormones and even our genetic
expression stays exactly equal to how
you think how you act and how you feel
now how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality that's it
so then if you believe just the
slightest bit in this idea that your
personality creates your personal
reality
and you wanted to change your personal
reality
that means you'd have to begin to change
your personality by thinking about what
you've been thinking about and changing
to begin to become conscious of your
unconscious habits and behaviors and
modify them
and then look at the emotions
that keep you connected to past
experiences
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality
as the same personality and it doesn't
work we literally have to become someone
else
so reason this with me
a habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
frequent repetition a habit is when
you've done something so many times that
your body knows how to do it as well as
your mind
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
ninety percent of the time
as the day before
you're demonstrating the same behaviors
ninety percent of the time and you're
embracing the same emotions as the day
before ninety percent of the time
over time you begin to fire the same
circuits in your brain in the same
sequences and the same patterns and the
same combinations
now there's a principle in neuroscience
that says that nerve cells that fire
together wire together
so as you think the same thoughts that
lead to the same choices that of course
produce the same behaviors that lead to
the same experiences that ultimately
produce the same emotions
that in time you begin to hardwire your
brain
into the same finite pattern
now that box in your brain there's no
literal box in your brain
but that finite signature ultimately
becomes your identity
so then most people by the time they're
35 years old become a set of memorized
behaviors
emotional reactions unconscious
attitudes beliefs and perceptions
that function like a subconscious
computer program
95 percent of who you are by the time
you're 35 years old is a memorized state
of being in which you've done something
so many times that your body now is
doing it better than your brain every
time you learn something new you add a
new stitch to the three-dimensional
tapestry of your gray matter
and if you begin to think about what you
learned
you're causing your brain to fire in new
sequences and new patterns and new
combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action
so we could say then that new thoughts
should lead to new choices
and new choices
should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences and new experiences then
should create new emotions and those new
emotions should inspire new thoughts
and that's called the evolution person's
doing the vision board and they're
saying when i get my new car i get my
new house i get my new relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
uh to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being thoughts are the vocabulary of the
brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you come come back
to your senses with a clean slate and
you say i don't feel anything you say
well let me start thinking about all the
problems in my life well all those
problems are connected to different
people or different objects of things at
different times and places the moment
you remember your problems a memory is a
record of the past you're thinking in
the past every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with them so all
of a sudden you start feeling unhappy
you start feeling bitter you start
feeling frustrated so now your body's in
the past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass because that feeling
is going to drive your behaviors it's
going to drive more of those thoughts
and when you feel that feeling and it's
visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've left that program behind a long
time ago they actually don't care how
you think of them they actually are so
happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
one of the things about the global
pandemic that i said to my staff and to
my family the moment i heard how the
circumstances in the world changed
i just said i refuse to be a victim
to these circumstances so a victim
consciousness is when
we allow something in our outer
environment to control the way we feel
and think so i said to you jay why are
you so upset today and you said oh it's
because of this person or circumstance
what you're really saying is
something in my outer environment some
person or some condition is controlling
the way i think and feel and that's not
the truth that's just the response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so
we're giving our life force we're giving
our power away to that circumstance and
so i just made up my mind that uh it was
a great opportunity to get into the
cocoon we've done an experiment just 10
minutes a day
three times a day with 120 people
trading resentment frustration fear for
gratitude appreciation and thankfulness
measuring their immune response
the the chemical immunoglobulin a your
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses the best flu shot you'll ever
get lives innately within you turns out
when you're frustrated when you're
impatient when you're fearful the immune
system dials down because you're an
emergency it's not it's all your energy
is going for some threat in your outer
world there's no energy in your inner
world for growth and repair but how do
you turn that around so then as people
begin to open their heart
can that chemical begin
to to elevate
four days
50
changed in 120 people their their iga
levels went up 50 in four days that's
your body's immune system is now up
regulating genes that are making
proteins and immunoglobulins and
antibodies that you don't need a flu
shot in other words your inner state is
greater than your outer world so then
just by doing that we now know that your
immune system is going to get stronger
by the same means
take 120 people or 50 people and measure
7500 gene regulations
okay
in four days
two genes that suppress cancer growth
and tumors are activated and upregulated
the genes that stimulate stem cells to
go to damaged tissues and repair them up
regulate them the gene for oxidative
balance is upregulated anti-cancer
anti-aging anti-heart disease
anti-stroke anti-neurodegenerative
anti-inflammatory antimicrobial just
your body's naturally doing this
the gene for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning this is four
days the gene switches on
the gene for more balance in the
pituitary in the pancreas the gene for
the microtubules of the cells the the
little the little fibers that respond to
energy and frequency so in four days we
now know that you can change your
genetic destiny
if you just practice the inner work
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there